with just one blog post a young engineer
would go on to completely shift
diversity hiring in tech
tracy chow is not your average woman in
stem
[Music]
tracy is a software engineer who has
been employed at some of the top tech
companies in the world
i grew up in silicon valley the daughter
of two software engineers and computer
scientists so you could say in some ways
that it was always in my blood but as
she entered into the offices of silicon
valley
she experienced the unsettling feeling
that can come from being the lone woman
and a lot of people
flirting with me or hitting on me or
giving me gifts it was
more than a year into working full time
that i
first had the realization that
i might be treated differently because i
was a woman when i was treated
differently i thought that it was more
due to something wrong with me
as more people started talking about
these issues i started to see that my
experience was not unique and that i
wasn't crazy
[Music]
there was no question in tracy's mind
that there was a pervasive sexist
culture throughout her industry but she
needed the numbers to prove it there
were no numbers across industry overall
and so in the back of my head i would
actually keep a running count of who the
other female engineers were and who the
other minorities were i realized also
that people weren't tracking that data i
think in some ways it's because it's
easier to ignore the problem if you're
not looking at any data on it that made
me think we really do need to put these
numbers down so she took matters into
her own hands she published her
company's gender diversity stats on
medium more and more people started
sharing it the first big company that
released their data was google and then
all the other companies really wanted to
follow suit
later seeing apple and amazon i realized
that there was actually a connection and
that me on my side
writing a little medium post and
tweeting about it in my little world
actually could have an impact on the
larger industry
tracy no longer refers to herself as
just an engineer she's also become one
of tech's most impassioned diversity
advocates co-founding project include a
non-profit that uses data to help tech
companies diversify their staff
now that we're having much more
discussion around diversity people who
are having
less great experiences and understand
that it's not necessarily them and that
there are bigger structural problems
that need to be addressed
sometimes when i feel down i'll actually
be lucky to get someone reaching out
sometimes it's a younger woman
in industry or maybe someone still in
school will say thank you for doing this
work i'm doing my little part to make
the industry better for the people who
are coming after me
[Music]
you